des gilets jaunes encore sous le choc
photos à l'appui ils montrent que l'on a
peut-être ici éviter le pire
ce matin à 7 heures un automobiliste
excédé aurait forcé le barrage
il a en tout cas fini sa course dans un
camion citerne un peu dramatique qu
est-ce qu on était une dizaine de
personnes autour du rond point et on a
eu vraiment le réflexe de s'écarter
parce que sinon c'est clair qui nous
écrase est il avait la volonté nous
écraser de toute façon depuis bientôt
trois semaines les gilets jaunes filtre
les accès de ce dépôt de carburant il
bloque temporairement les camions les
chauffeurs eux prennent leur mal en
patience
un peu plus compliqué que oui qu'à
l'habitude mais bon après il faut on
comprend le le mouvement à toute façon
qu'ils ont fait avec mais sinon oui ça
va c'est compliqué mais pas non plus ça
va encore dans leur région ici tous les
matins de 5h à 9h c'est le même rituel
filtrage des camions-citernes
circulation alternée des voitures bref
une belle pagaille
suivi de près par les policiers on
attend qu'ils partent
et on remet le barrage en place et ils
vont venir certainement tout à l'heure
dont ce qu'on fera on laissera les
calmants passé et de nouveaux bloquera
le but c'est vraiment de faire du
harcèlement pour qu'on bloque
complètement de ses racines et
effectivement quelques minutes plus tard
les forces de l'ordre ont fait leur
retour est demandé aux manifestants de
lever le camp levée de barrages qui
s'est faite dans le plus grand calme en
attendant la prochaine action